c'est ce à quoi vous pensez c'est les
petites histoires d'horreur qui nous
font bien bas des épisodes 68 3
histoires d'horreur cette fois sans
inviter parce que il faut varier les
plaisirs et pas parce que j'ai pas
réussi à trouver des gens autour de moi
qui ont des histoires d'horreur a
raconté aujourd'hui au programme on a
une histoire courte une histoire très
longue et re une histoire courte c'est
le programme d'aujourd'hui ce qui vous
plaît
oui non dites moi voilà j'ai pas envie
de parler milan on rentre tout de suite
dans le vif du sujet avec l'histoire de
aude modèle à un petit job d'appoint
c'est le baby sitting voilà elle en fait
ça lui permet entre autres de financer
ses sorties entre potes et ses jeux
vidéo c'est elle même qui le dit et elle
a donc un second téléphone dédié à cette
activité pour la simple et bonne raison
que son numéro et un peu partout dans la
rue puisque hot pour trouver des clients
des gens qui font appel à elle est belle
mais des affiches
bref ce jour là le jour de l'accident il
est 15h et quelqu'un contact aude sur
son second téléphone du voilà c'est un
message tout à fait normale de quelqu'un
qui lui demande si elle est disponible
samedi qui suit et aude répond tout de
suite et lui envoie les horaires
auxquels il est disponible samedi qui
suit elle expliqué quelques échanges
parfaitement normaux entre temps avec la
personne notamment sur le temps de la
prestation sur ciel doit récupérer les
clés ou s'ils émettent soupaya sion ce
genre de bêtises des trucs tout à fait
normaux qu'elle a déjà vu plein de fois
et ce n'est qu'un peu plus tard dans la
journée que o2 reçoit un message moins
habituel pour le coup le papa ou la
maman lui demande d'envoyer une photo
d'elle
pourquoi pas c'est vrai qu'on sait
jamais trop sur qui on tombe avec ses
annonces qu'on trouve dans la rue donc
peut-être que ça rassure de voir la
personne je sais pas dans le doute
odeurs refuse elle n'en voit pas la
photo et la personne en face d'un
système le lendemain nouveau message de
ce client et là c'est vraiment bizarre
la personne lui demande par message si
elle aime les hommes plus âgés qu'elle
inutile de préciser que c'est pas
vraiment une question normale à poser à
quelqu'un que tu mens date pour du baby
sitting aude explique qu'elle a juste
ignorer le message est que ça na pas
alarmer plus que ce qu'elle a déjà eu
plein de messages lourd de gens comme ça
dans sa vie mais pas nos clients et
c'est là où elle dit [ __ ] ça aurait
quand même dû m'alerter bref le jour j
arrive on est samedi et elle appelle un
hubert pour se rendre à la maison où
elle doit garder du coup l'enfant aude
arrivent sur les lieux et là elle
vérifie si elle est bien à la bonne
adresse parce que la maison qu'elle a
devant elle ne ressemble pas du tout aux
maisons dans lesquelles elle a
l'habitude de se rendre elle se tient
face à une vieille maison à deux étages
elle constate que deux des fenêtres sont
cassées et que le bois a l'air de
pourrir que la plupart des planches il
ya des trous dedans elle passe le
portail et ce en marchant vers la maison
qu'elle s'arrête
parce qu'elle aperçoit quelqu'un à l'une
des fenêtres ce qui est personnellement
ma phobie
il y à un homme qui a l'air d'avoir la
quarantaine qui se tient là avec sur la
tête ce qui a l'air de ressembler à une
couronne de fleurs et surtout il a
quelque chose dans la main mais elle
n'arrive pas à voir ce que co2 restent
figées regarde cet homme et après
plusieurs secondes tu as plus sprint de
sa vie elle explique même qu'elle a
tellement couru qu'à un moment elle sert
hamas sur un trottoir et c'est là
qu'elle a décidé d'appeler sa mère pour
qu'elle vienne la chercher et elle
explique encore aujourd'hui elle a ce
visage de ce mec ancré dans sa tête et
bien évidemment elle s'est très souvent
posé cette question cette fameuse
question du [ __ ] si j'étais entré dans
la maison et que j'avais pas regardé la
fenêtre
qu'est ce qui me serait arrivé quoi bref
si vous faites du baby-sitting attention
mais c'est mon unique conseil dans cette
vidéo deuxième histoire beaucoup plus
longue est absolument horrible ahmed est
un américain qui explique être parti
vivre aux états unis dans les années 90
et la bonne nouvelle c'est que c'est aux
états unis qu'il a rencontrée ce qui est
actuellement sa femme avec qui il a
désormais deux enfants voilà c'est le
seul truc positif de l'histoire j'espère
que vous avez bien profité
bref il explique qu'à l'époque pour lui
les temps étaient durs il alternait
entre deux emplois juste pour pouvoir se
payer à manger et avoir un toit
au-dessus de la tête il explique que
tout ce qui pouvait se permettre en
termes de logement c'était l'appartement
le plus pourri d'un vieux bâtiment
décrépi dans un quartier clairement pas
ouf
en gros il explique que c'était
tellement craignos la barre que genre y
avait pas une nuit où il se réveillait
pas à cause d'un coup de feu ont été
tirés
bref voilà il explique c'était vraiment
un endroit qui détestait qui était
vraiment pas ouf mais il n'avait pas le
choix parce qu'il avait très peu
d'argent il explique que son deuxième
emploi c'était barman dans un strip
clubs vous l'avez compris avec cet
emploi et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il
nous parle de cet emploi là et pas de
son premier emploi qui lui est deux
jours
il rentrait tard chez lui plus
précisément il rentrait du coup tous les
soirs autour de 2 3 heures du mat qui
est une heure on peut se le dire pas
très rassurante durant ta de trois
heures tu es un peu sur tes gardes quand
même c'était un samedi soir fin de
semaine ahmed rentrer chez lui il est
épuisé il explique que ce soir là comme
tous les autres soirs il est entré dans
son immeuble qu'il a commencé à marcher
vers l'ascenseur de l'immeuble et qu'en
levant la tête il a vu que devant
l'ascenseur se trouvait un mime un mime
pour ceux qui savent pas c'est un acteur
qui joue des rôles mais les mises ont un
code vestimentaire que respecter très
bien ce mime lac était devant
l'ascenseur de l'immeuble d'ahmed à
mettre constate que ce mime dans une
main il tient un ballon attaché à une
ficelle et que de l'autre main il lui
fait coucou et il explique que c'est pas
un coucou comme nous on peut faire c'est
un coucou très mécanique
amy mais à cause de la peur à mettre
décide de prendre les escaliers et il en
a pour un moment puisqu'il habite au 9e
étage tout ce qu'il importait c'était en
aucun cas de s'approcher de ce mime
ahmed monte les marches avec un certain
rythme et c'est qu'une fois arrivé au
quatrième ou cinquième étage que du coin
de l'oeil
il voit quelque chose bougeait il
s'arrête net il se retourne pour voir ce
que c'est et douche froide le mime et
dans la cage d'escalier en train de
monter les marches et ce qui terrorise
ahmed c'est qu'ils m'ont pas les marches
normalement il monte les marches vous
savez comme dans les vieux films muets
qu un personnage veut montrer qu'il
essaie d'être discret et marche sur la
pointe des pieds
le gars dans la cage d'escalier fait
exactement la même chose
il est dans son père socoa et là le mime
s'aperçoit km la repérer et d'un coup il
se fige la hamaide commence à vraiment
avoir peur et décide de lui parler il
lui dit en riant nerveusement mec arrête
en gros il s'est dit que le gars en face
s'entraîner ou qui faisait une sorte de
performance bref peu importe
et quand lui disant c'est bon t'es trop
fort bien joué c'était cool le gars
allaient arrêter aucune réaction de la
part du mime
il reste là sans bouger dans la même
position qu'à une minute et il attend
c'est la km réalise qu'il ya un problème
et qui se met à courir pour rejoindre le
neuvième étage mais malheureusement
quand il se met à courir il entend le
mime qui fait la même chose que lui
ahmed cette fois ils cèdent et il hurle
sur le mime il lui demande pourquoi il
fait ça qu'est ce qu'il veut et il lui
demande surtout de lui [ __ ] la paix et
d'un coup l'expression du visage du mime
change et il se met à être triste
ou plutôt à jouer la tristesse et à ce
moment précis ahmed comprend que le gars
en face il n'est pas là pour déconner et
qu'il a très probablement de mauvaises
intentions il arrive devant sa porte
d'entrée il ouvre à une vitesse folle et
rentre chez lui et là il est sous le
choc de ce qui vient de vivre il réalise
même pas en fait c'est au moment où il
reprend ses esprits où il pensait être
tirée d'affaires qui se met entendre des
frottements quand sa porte d'entrée
venant évidemment de l'extérieur après
quelques dizaines de secondes
ahmed explique qui prend son courage à
deux mains qui n'a pas le choix et qui
va voir à travers l'oeil et de sa porte
d'entrée et malheureusement le mime et
bien là devant sa porte et il se met à
fixer le y ait un sourire ahmed il reste
bouche bée regardant à travers l'oeil et
de la porte
il est complètement choqués ils arrivent
plus à bouger il est tétanisé et le mime
mais ses paumes de mains de chaque côté
de son visage ouvre la bouche comme
s'ils étaient étonnés et il se met à
faire des cliquetis avec sa langue et à
chaque clip qui y tape avec son pied
dans la porte
ahmed comprend que le gars va trop loin
trop loin pour un mec qu'a pas de
mauvaises intentions et il comprend
qu'il doit se barrer de la parte parce
que tôt ou tard le mec va c'est de
rentrer chez lui fort heureusement à sa
fenêtre ahmed est là
sortie de secours vous savez ces
escaliers en fer qui sont collés aux
bâtiments et qui permettent d'évacuer en
cada centre ahmed fond sur ses escaliers
et il entend un énorme bruit qui est
tout simplement celui de la porte
d'entrée qui vient de céder
ahmed arrive en bas des escaliers et
continue de courir sans regarder
derrière lui et après trente mètres il
se retourne et c'est là qu'il a vu le
mime pour la dernière fois de sa vie
juste devant la fenêtre de sa chambre en
fixant avec un grand sourire avant de
lever les mains et d'applaudir à berne
pour ahmed il était absolument hors de
question de revenir dans cet appart donc
il a logé chez des amis de temps trouver
un nouvel appartement et heureusement
pour lui il explique ça s'est fait très
rapidement il a plus jamais eu news de
semis marques comme il l'a dit et il a
un bon trop bas il n'a toujours pas
compris si le mec juste était un
psychopathe qui s'amusaient ou si il
avait une réelle intention de chez pas
de le cambrioler deux il a rien compris
comme toi y'a rien d'un conte promet
qu'à part ce bar est très loin est rien
à comprendre
bref c'est horrible tout ça nous amène à
la dernière histoire qui est celle de
olivia il ya quelques semaines il est
21h passé et olivia et dans sa voiture
avec son enfant elle est sur une
autoroute du nord de la californie elle
rejoint son mari qui se trouve chez ses
parents tout ça très peu d'importance
qui est important c'est qu'elle est
seule dans sa voiture et que son fils
est à l'arrière de la voiture en train
de dormir
elle roule tranquillement sur une route
à sens unique constituée de deux voix et
qui plus loin devient une route à une
seule voie peu avant que la route ne
devienne qu'une seule voie il ya une
voiture qui se met à rouler au même
niveau qu'au liban une voiture qui
semble faire partie de celles que les
policiers utilisent quand ils sont en
civil
bref la voiture ralentit pour laisser
olivia s'insérer dans l'unique voie que
devient cette route mais mauvaise
surprise la voiture allume son gyrophare
olivier explique que la voiture qui se
trouve derrière elle est toute noire et
que du coup elle n'arrive même pas à
voir à quoi ressemble le conducteur de
cette dernière mais elle veut pas de
problème donc elle se gare sur le bord
de la route et la voiture du coup vient
se garer derrière elle olivia prépare
son permis et ses papiers d'assurance en
vue du contrôle qui va probablement lui
tomber dessus et pas de surprise un
homme en uniforme du coup sort de la
voiture de derrière et s'approche de sa
vitre à elle une fois arrivé au niveau
de sa fenêtre
olivia baisse la vitre et lui dit est ce
que j'ai fait quelque chose de mal et
elle le dit sincèrement elle le dit pas
comme vous et moi parfois quand on se
fait contrôler et qu'on sait ce qu'on a
fait et elle elle comprend vraiment pas
parce que là où elle a doublé le
policier qui en plus a ralenti exprès
pour l'année s'est passé c'est une zone
où le dépassement est autorisée après
avoir posé sa question
via elle réalise qu en fait l'homme qui
est à la fenêtre de sa voiture c'est pas
un uniforme qu'ils portent c'est juste
une tenue toute noire
le gars il ressemble à une ombre quoi
dans le noir on ne voit pas du tout et
comme pour aude la baby sitter elle
explique qu'au début elle n'a pas
percuté ça n'a pas alarmer plus que ça
et qu après qu elle a réalisé à quel
point c'était grave en fait bref elle
lui tentant même son permis de conduire
lui redemande en est ce que j'ai fait
quelque chose de mal je comprends pas et
le monsieur à sa fenêtre prend son
permis et l'inspecteur pendant pas loin
d'une minute ce qui est très long pour
inspecter un permis ça prend vraiment
pas ce temps minutes à l'issue de
laquelle le monsieur rend à olivia son
permis sans avoir encore dit un seul mot
et c'est ce qui fait qu olivia comprend
qu'il ya quelque chose qui est étrange
et dans un élan de courage et lui
demande en s'excusant son numéro de bab
et aussi le département de la police
dans lequel il travaille est ce cher
monsieur qui est très près d'olivia
rappelons le un puisqu'il est à sa
fenêtre ne répond toujours pas à ces
questions et la fixe pendant plusieurs
secondes avant de fixer son fils qui est
sur la banquette arrière en train de
dormir et après plusieurs secondes et
toujours aucun mot de sa part depuis
début de l'intervention il retourne à sa
voiture
il démarre et efficace olivia explique
qu'après ça elle était en panique et
elle a foncé chez sa belle famille en ne
respectant aucune des limitations de
vitesse tellement elle était dans l'
angoisse
elle n'a jamais revu ce mec qui n'était
définitivement pas un policier encore
aujourd'hui elle se pose beaucoup de
questions sur ce qui s'est passé elle se
demande par exemple ce que le mec aurait
fait s'il n'y avait pas à son fils qui
dormait sur la banquette arrière
bref ça l'a hanté pendant pas mal de
temps et c'est horrible parce que je me
suis toujours gestion robuste angoisses
de dire mais attends mais c'est sûr qu'à
défaut gyrophare sur le marché et c'est
assez convaincant pour que même si tu es
un doute tu t'arrêtes si jamais un mec
utilisent des rats toi parce que au cas
où ces des policiers t'as pas envie de
retrouver dans la merde parce que tu as
fait un délit de fuite ou je sais pas
quoi c'est tellement bas dans mon gars
c'est l'enfer c'est la fin de nos trois
histoires d'aujourd'hui donc là ce qui
va se passer c'est que vous allez plus
conduire vous allez plus faire de baby
sitting et feu n'allait plus rentrer
chez vous à 3 heures du matin par peur
de voir un mur devant votre ascenseur
j'adore je suis friand germes sont que
ça s'arrêtera jamais c'est rubio va il
ya toujours plus de mécanique toujours
plus de situations différentes et il
faut le dire juste j'en profite un petit
mot je deviens moi même un peu parano et
dans la vie moi même je regarde beaucoup
plus ou league avant moi même les rares
fois où je rentre tard le soir puisque
c'est pas du tout mon truc les soirées
jazz sûr d'être suivi je regarde un peu
derrière moi on développe tous des
symptômes post serait d'horreur mais
vous en faites pas ce genre de truc ça
n'arrivera qu'à vingt personnes parmi
nous et on espère juste que ce sera pas
nous n'est ce pas à très vite
[Musique]